Dear friends, I send my warmest wishes...
...as Muslims around the world begin observing...
...the holy months of Ramadan.
This is a moment of reflection and learning,...
...a time to come together...
...in a spirit of understanding and compassion,...
...bound by our common humanity.
That is also the mission of the United Nations:...
...to foster dialogue, unity and peace.
In these challenging times,...
...my thoughts are with those facing conflict,...
...displacement and suffering.
I join everyone observing Ramadan...
...to call for peace, mutual respect and solidarity.
Let us take inspiration from these holy months...
...and build a more just and equitable world for all.
Ramadan Kareem.